I wasn't trying to get kicked out of
Scientology I was trying to not get
kicked out of Scientology
I you know so what happened first first
my mom got kicked out for basically
talking some smack about David miscavige
and then they go to me and they go okay
you've got to disconnect from your mom
or you're going to get kicked out and I
lied about that I was like okay I'll
disconnect but I never did for a couple
years I lied my ass off about it
eventually they were like this guy's
gonna keep lying to us right and they're
like yeah like all right you're out
something go to my wife so you got to
divorce your husband or you're gonna get
kicked out and she goes no
that's a hell of a statement from her
it's gonna get harder from here so I'm
not quite sure how to
okay so I'll try to get I'll try to do
you don't seem like a man who's afraid
of hard things okay so she's like
no
so then they go to her parents
and they say you've got to disconnect
from your daughter
and your three granddaughters
oh you're gonna get kicked out
but they have three other kids who are
scientologists who have spouses who are
scientologists who have grandkids
so I feel like
up until that point everybody was sort
of making a decision for themselves and
what would be best for themselves
until they get to her parents
and then they're like which grandkids
are we gonna lose
okay
at the part where they were trying to
get me to disconnect from my mom
there were hours that I spent talking to
them going you know guys
there's another way
it doesn't have to go this way
there's another way that ends well for
all of us
and that wasn't even considered
and I go like
they created this monster
and that's a fact
and that's why I take joy in it
when people when people ask me a
Scientology a destructive cult I don't
even have to get into all the academic
discussions of what's a religion and
what's a cult and what's the difference
I go as long as they destroy families
like that they're occult
so they cut people off deliberately one
by one
and it doesn't have to be that way right
and why is it that way
I mean it started with L Ron Hubbard
laying out a policy framework a policy
structure that
if interpreted and applied in the worst
possible way with the worst possible
judgment can be abused in that way I
would make the argument
that if an anti-broker had taken over
that Scientology policy does have enough
little
um caveats baked into it that even the
policies about disconnection could be
interpreted and implemented in a
non-destructive way
there is room for judgment and
discretion
and miscavige has just created the worst
possible version of Scientology and
that's that's where you sort of get that
argument of does he even want
scientologies to succeed because he
seems to be hell-bent
on making sure that he doesn't
yeah and I don't want to see him make it
succeed but it does bring that question
up of like what are his motivations
can he not see that he's destroying the
thing he's supposed to be expanding
that's also you know there's ways to
measure cost
and that would probably be the most
costly aspect of Scientology is the
suffering associated with the separating
of families yeah I mean that's actually
just puts make it's a very concrete what
we value in human life
is the connection to our loved ones like
everything else doesn't matter like
getting 50 bucks a week
uh
like that like uh getting money stolen
from you
getting the truth stolen from you none
of that compares
uh you can even frame that as the good
there could be a lot of positives
whatever in the tribe but separating
families separating loved ones that's
the destructive thing
so no hate though no I genuinely don't
hate them
do you forgive them 100
there's no one I look at in Scientology
that I go how dare you if I was in their
shoes
having to you know operate under David
miscavigest orders I would have done the
same thing and I would have loved it
truthfully
I don't blame any of them I mean I take
the opposite approach if they knew what
I knew they'd be doing what I'm doing
yeah if they knew what I knew and
believed it they'd be doing what I'm
doing they're not dumb it's not it's not
it's not dumb people in Scientology
they're ambitious they're dreamers they
got hope they're driven all that kind of
stuff yeah
and it's one of the reasons I like
putting up content on my channel so they
can see hey like if you're a
Scientologist you look at that and you
go hey he seems like he's doing well
he's kind of he's happy he's a positive
guy he's a good communicator he knows
what he's talking about he's not lying
he's not exaggerating I don't exaggerate
anything on my channel I don't make up
anything
and this is actually comes from an
experience I had from 1998 to 2000 I was
living in La I sort of had a two year
period of my life where I actually had
almost no contact with Scientology
and during that time I found my way onto
the internet and there was a website it
might have been esmb ex-scientology
message but whatever it was it was at
that time the main source of critical
information about scientology on the
internet and I looked at it and remember
I was still a True Believer
and I looked at this and it was so
uh offensive
insulting uh hyperbolic exaggerated I
was like ah just a bunch of [__]
I was in Scientology for 16 more years
if
what I had seen on the internet about
critical of Scientology if what I had
seen when I had seen it was something
that actually resonated with me
that I was like oh
that I believed was true that's
incredible
I would have gotten out of Scientology
16 years earlier so I was like
how can I help create an experience on
the internet that if a Scientologist
stumbles upon it it will resonate with
them instead of repelling them and that
is exactly what I have set out to do and
what I believe I've accomplished there's
the content the message but also just
showing that you can be happy outside of
Scientology exactly you can have a
fulfilling life you could be a good man
yeah all that